bonsoir ce soir dans enquêtes d'actu un
phénomène tendance la merguez sur les
podiums en couverture des magazines la
merguez fait l'objet de tous les
fantasmes dépendance abus taches de gras
la merguez a aussi sa part d'ombré au
point de faire trembler les plus hautes
sphères de l'état
alors à qui profite le business de la
merguez qui tire les ficelles qu'est-ce
que tu bois doudou dis dont un reportage
de jean noël plancha et youri djorkaeff
derrière le business de la merguez un
seul homme
raul béarnaise qui a refusé toutes nos
demandes la paye j'ai pas le temps
raul béarnais se livrent depuis 20 ans à
une lutte sans merci avec bernard boyau
le petit prince de la chipolata nous
avons mené l enquête au coeur des
réseaux parallèles de la merguez go-fast
de merguez merguez vendus sous le
manteau
la merguez a encore de beaux jours
devant elle mais à quel prix depuis ce
reportage
raul bernese est derrière les barreaux
il a été interpellé au volant de sa
luxueuse berline à la frontière
mexicaine avec un son bord 500 kg de
merguez cacher a varié
la semaine prochaine nous reviendrons
sur les dérives sectaires causés par les
cordons bleus
bonne soirée et bonne mise en plis sur
d8 les gros